i i just wonder you know the big
question is what inspired you to
embark on this campaign which
potentially
uh could be political and reputational
suicide for you
well let the electorate judge that i
mean the latest polls are rather good
for alipa showing us getting
parliamentary representation
which is no mean feat because today adam
we're celebrating our third anniversary
we've been in existence for precisely
three weeks
so we've already overtaken the liberal
democrats in membership
we've got twice as many mps behind me
there as the
scottish labour party does and today's
polls show us making a breakthrough of
five seats so that's not bad in three
weeks adam but less than the electoral
judge
in three weeks time all i can tell you
is i'm enjoying myself enormously
okay but if we look at the opinion polls
you are less
going to ask themselves why you won't
just issue a public apology
to the women that you worked with when
you were first minister
uh for your behaviour
well i i like the way you wave away the
trials i mean
this is a trial in front of a jury in
which i was acquitted
a jury incidentally with a majority of
women on it in front of a
lady judge and if you knew about the
issue adam you know there was the policy
issued
almost 10 years ago not for what i was
accused of incidentally
the jury dealt with that but having been
acquitted in the highest criminal court
in scotland and indeed won my case
against the scottish government
in the highest civil court in scotland
then i think most people most
fair-minded people
would say that's that it's time to move
on most people really think sky
i don't think sky television
incidentally i don't think sky
television should be trying to
retry me well i'm trying to retry it i'm
just being very frank with you you've
got legal protections
but to me it's surprising that you won't
do the simple
human thing of saying i'm sorry
for any of the offenses which i may of
course irrespective
of of your legal position
sorry adam let me repeat it an apology
was issued and accepted 10
years ago 10 years ago but now you're
running you're trying to come back into
politics you're a party leader
shouldn't you issue an apology i mean to
say i apologize for something 10 years
ago won't really convince a lot of
people
so look i just explained to people
you're coming through a voice in my
right hand side so if you keep
interrupting me it's going to make the
interview impossible because you're
being picked up in a microphone here
the issue adam was not only was it 10
years ago i apologized i apologize last
year
when i was tried in front of a court the
jury decided
the jury's in the verdict's in adam it's
time to to move on in this statement
we've had two uh
court cases criminal court civil court
we had three inquiries
these have happened they are over with
let's
move on that's what most fair-minded
people in scotland wants to do
and let's let the people judge whether
or not the aleppo party is going to be
successful okay
it's a great respect this is evidence
given by two female civil servants
is it true that when you were first
minister you asked female aides to
tie your shoelaces to remove dandruff
and to apply hand sanitizer no it was
complete rubbish incidentally
and even incidentally the scottish
government inquiry
the one incidentally which was found
unlawful unfair and tainted by
bias didn't establish that fight so stop
believing rubbish adam well
it's on the way okay so it's not true
all i need to know
right let's let's talk about your your
party and some of your
candidates uh uh you've got a candidate
jim walker
uh he described nicola sturgeon online
as a cow
uh do you support that sort of approach
to the first minister well that
that was i mean that was a uh a twitter
exchange before jim was a candidate jim
is one of the
most significant economists in the world
incidentally he was the asian money
economist of the year 11 years running
right that's more than the celtic one in
terms of premier championships items so
let's give jim
some credit all right world renowned
economist not going to twitter spots i
mean nicholas sturgeon has said some
hard things about me but this campaign
alipa
and all our candidates once they become
candidates
go forward in an entirely positive
agenda about scotland's future
that's the discourse i'm hoping for do
you agree even when you see
she said nicolas sturgeon has said this
about this is about personalities and
your ego
so do you agree with jim walker that
nicolas sturgeon is a cow
no and neither does jim walker who
apologized for that remark of course not
and i haven't made a single
personal remark about nicholas sturgeon
or anyone else in this campaign
because i think politics is about
national issues the national anthem
let's talk let's talk about national
issues let's talk about uh
romanian beggars we've got alex arthur
here another one of your candidates who
tweeted
them romanian beggars in edinburgh ain't
hungry
uh just drove past them all ready to
switch up begging posts
and all of them fat as big juicy overfed
pigs
uh is that the sort of person you want
representing aleppo
are we talking about alec arthur the
world champion and obe
is that the person you're talking about
well i don't know it's the person who's
the person who tweeted that
listen i'm telling you a world champion
and an obe
yes that's the sort of person we want a
standing person
that's the sort of person representing
you you know adam
even you i'm sure have said things you
regret on twitter and apologized for
them
nobody has said anything like that as an
aleppo candidate
therefore let's move on to the substance
of the election
incidentally i wouldn't take your
information from the
mainstream press in scotland i mean
these are people who have slept through
this sermon on the mount
let's talk about politics well i speak
to my colleagues and i'm very proud
to get advice from my colleagues james
matthews our scotland correspondent who
looks into these things and i think you
would respect james john matthews well
jim matthews an
excellent correspondent i think jim
matthews i would say
in terms of his coverage of scottish
politics and identity
his coverage of the investigations and
to me is the exception that proves the
rules
i mean james matthews has has raised
these issues with me and and just the
final one
uh margaret lee james matthews has
raised this she's sorry jim's
james matthews has raised these issues
with me but if i may say so adam
he's met raised him in a very fair
intelligent discourse way
a wee bit unlike the interviewer you're
conducting
the opportunity as the party leader uh
to
uh to clear things up for your
candidates
okay just one final one the question of
the question of margaret lynch
um she is uh alleged by lgp
t organizations to have said that that
they want to lower the age of consent to
10 which they don't is there any truth
in that
no truth whatsoever and if you've read
the scotsman today you'd have read
mark okay rotary scott's been explaining
yesterday
so stop feeding me this total rubbish
and let's get on with politics
ask me about the election council i'm
going to ask you about the election
campaign but i mean you would agree that
reputation matters though don't you you
you know recognize
adam you can do much better than that
the viewers never mind me let's talk
about particularly i apologize
that the covered rules didn't allow you
to come into the studio personally i
regret that but we
we follow the company rules then adapt
to the rules adam
ask me a question okay i'm going to ask
you a question what is the grand
strategy
uh given alipa's standing
the number of seats it's likely to get
assuming it all goes rosy and you get
those half a dozen seats
what is that what is the strategy what
are you going to do with that
no if we el goes rosie adam we'll get a
lot more than that but i think it's
significant that we're making that
breakthrough according to the poll
this morning and my one poll is just one
poll we've got three weeks to go
let's hope we do better than that but
even if we took that paul adam
that would give the independence parties
in the scottish parliament
80 seats out of a parliament of 129 what
we call a super majority
and on that super majority we think that
boris johnson is much less likely to be
able to say no
to that sort of parliamentary majority
than he does if it's just prime minister
against first minister torres against
the snp
because he'll be taking on an entire
parliament representing an entire nation
that's why we want to cast the debate in
that fashion
isn't he more likely to say i've said
all along i'm not going to
grant another referendum because they're
once in a generation
and even the independence movement
amongst itself
is fighting like rats in a sack so
why should i uh bother with that
well i think we'd probably say
santander's agreement or belfast
agreement and remember
seven years is the period between
referendum agreed by the cabinet office
northern ireland
i think if it's good enough for northern
ireland it's good enough for scotland
and lo and behold it's seven years
since the last scottish referendum but
what matters is the verdict to the
scottish people
and if they put in a supermajority into
the parliament
then i think boris johnson is in a much
weaker position
and if he's just allowed to continue to
cast this as prime minister against
first minister
let's make it a tory prime minister
against the scottish nation
that's what you're doing because he's
going to say uh is it
nicholas sturgeon or is it alex salmon
that your re-entry into politics
gives him that opportunity you know adam
i did a
press conference yesterday with 104
international journalists from around
europe
not one of them asked me the question
about having a variety of parties
because they all operate under
proportional systems like the one we
have in scotland
but it's normal to have lots of
political parties now i think it
strengthens the independence movement
to have a number of political parties
advocating independence increases the
appeal and the bread for the movement
that's what aleppo does what's not
normal is to have a former
party leader and national leader to
defect
and run against his successor that's
quite unusual
well it's i mean look there's 15 parties
in the danish parliament there's about
nine in the finnish parliament arguing
in some cases for similar objectives
the difference between aleppa and the
smp which is the real question
it's a quick question of where we get to
independence is a question of urgency
and the alipa policy is that in one
month's time
if we get that super majority which the
poll this morning suggests
we'll lay down a motion instructing the
scottish government
to open negotiations with the
westminster government on independence
for scotland so the difference between
aleppo and the smp and
even more so the greens who are pretty
weak on independence
is a question of urgency we think it's
an immediate priority
and we should get on with it if you were
successful
and you obtained scottish independence
would you be prepared and membership of
the european union would you
be prepared to see a border across great
britain
well you say membership the european
union i mean one of the policies we're
discussing this weekend that our second
conference after three weeks in
existence
is our whole approach to europe because
we would see that the immediate priority
now that scotland has been dragged
out of the european union against her
will our immediate priority is to get
back into the single market because we
can do that relatively quickly
whereas as you're well aware european
union membership will take
best will in the world number one if you
can get back into the single market
then of course it opens up a range of
possibilities
no in norway for example is in the
single market but not in the customs
union
you could have a customs union with the
rest of the uk which of course has
significant implications in terms of the
type of border you would have between
scotland and england one thing's for
sure
you've been a common travel area that's
exactly what's going on on the island of
ireland at the moment and what we're
seeing
is it's very difficult uh to avoid a
border
uh they we've had an easter egg well
i'll tell you what i'll tell you what's
going on in island of ireland this now
uh a reckless tory prime minister has
jeopardized and sacrificed the peace in
northern ireland
that so many people have struggled for
over the last 40 years
because he doesn't have the wisdom or
the vision to understand the
implications of his understanding let's
hope
you may say that the same mistakes
is if we have a situation where scotland
was in the single market and presumably
the customs union
there would have to be a border wouldn't
there of some kind uh across the united
kingdom
across sorry well the position would
when the position would depend if you
were in or not in the customs union the
point i was going to make to you that
the common travel area
which has existed in these islands since
the 1920s
would still prevail so adam bolton if he
so wished
with no inhibition whatsoever could come
up to edinburgh once the covered rules
are relaxed
and interview me in front of the
scottish parliament if i am successful
in being elected no restrictions
with me would i that's the situation
that people are experiencing lorry
drivers going into france for example
so there would be a police border
wouldn't it i mean there's a serious
matter
incidentally about food standards i mean
given the world that
boris johnson wants to take this country
in and not harm sandwiches but just
think of the implications in terms of
food additives
i mean there are good arguments for
having food protection and in a
post-covered environment
i think people are going to be
extraordinarily sensitive and want the
maximum
environmental protection for the
foodstuffs and other things so don't
dismiss
the the regulatory checks and food
substances adam
that would be not understanding some of
the lessons and the harsh lessons we've
been taught over the last year
will you and nicolas sturgeon after this
election will you have a joint campaign
for a scottish referendum and a joint
campaign
for a yes vote if that referendum takes
place
oh yes but not just with nicola sturgeon
but with everybody prepared to
to campaign for yes i mean one of the
things i learned one of the mistakes i
made adam is
as first minister although we were
hugely successful in making the snp the
dominant force in scottish politics
we didn't move the dial on independence
until 2014.
so we became the dominant force in
scottish politics but support for
independence was still stuck about 30
it was only in 2014 in that high
glorious summer
but the yes campaign broadened to
include a whole range of multi-various
groups arguing for independence from a
different point of view
that we started to have the momentum
behind yes and if i was to express
aleppo as one thing
i i would say it's the that glorious yes
diverse movement reborn
in the form of a political party
optimistic forward-looking
open-minded and arguing constructively
with anyone who's prepared to
support the cause of independence for
scotland and finally if that seems
likely boris johnson does not agree
to a binding referendum would you insist
on the holding
of an indicative referendum uh whatever
whatever the position in westminster is
i think there's a range of tactics can
be employed and that's certainly one of
them but listen
if i could make david cameron as a tory
prime minister in trouble now
but a much more impressive tory prime
minister than boris johnson will ever be
if i could make
david cameron back down in 2012 then the
yes movement can make
boris johnson back down in 2021
okay you raised david cameron what do
you make of this
westminster lobbying scandal well i mean
it it does look pretty bad but listen
listen we haven't heard the the full
facts uh
there's going to be i think seven
inquiries i'm counting and i think we
should give him
the benefit they don't until here's this
full account but i mean the lobbying
scandal looks pretty bad it doesn't
alter the fact that when he was in
office
despite the fact i disagreed with him
and just about everything including
scottish independence
then he looked like a prime minister but
he'll get his opportunity in front of
these seven enquiries
to explain what an earth was going on